All right, thank you
so much, Sam. Shannon and I
are going to be talking a
little bit about the thematic
and bootstrap lib
packages today.
In short, these are new
packages to theme Shiny
as well as R Markdown and
traditional web content.
And we're really
excited about kind
of the breadth of
what this can do
for theming and kind of the
ease of use to get started.
So first off, introducing
these packages,
bootstrap lib or we're
calling bslib is really just
simplify theming of web
content via bootstrap.
Now web content,
meaning could be Shiny,
could be R Markdown
and bootstrap,
as well as for
traditional web pages,
so there's a lot of power there.
Thematic, on the other hand, is
kind of a complementary package
to bslib,
which is simplified
theming of our plots,
meaning ggplot,
lattice, base, and plot,
that is, kind of works in
conjunction with bslib.
Both of these have
packagedown websites
where you can find out a
lot more info about them.
Thematic is on CRAN
already and bslib is kind
of waiting in the queue, so it
should hopefully be the next
few days.
If you want to get
started with them today
you can always install the
dev versions from GitHub,
as you can see here with this
code. And a big thanks
to Carson Sievert who
let me adapt some of his slides
for today's presentation.
He's one of the core
developers working
on both bootstrap lib
and thematic as part
of our Shiny team.
So first off, for
some folks, you
may have been using Shiny
before, you may have been using
R Markdown before, but less
people are kind of aware
of using bootstrap natively.
And what this is,
is really just a lot
of CSS and JavaScript
plug-ins for front end web
development.
You can dive deeper
into bootstrap
and we're going have a great
presentation about SASS,
which is using these variables
right after this presentation.
But in short, this
is kind of working
behind the scenes in bslib and other packages
and kind of provides you all
these nice things without you
having to know about it.
So bootstrap lib is a wrapper
around custom bootstrap themes
and makes it really easy
to theme your documents
and use things
like SASS variables
without having to write all
this custom css out
of the box.
Now, if you do
know those skills,
and if you gain those skills
from someone like Appsilon,
or have them working
with you, they
can further expand
your applications
with css  or sass variables.
But again, this is
really kind of an R
interface and
functions where you
don't have to know all
of it to get started.
And again, you've been
using components of this
through Shiny and
RMarkdown for years,
you just probably
didn't know it.
So to start using
bslib, it's
really just a
one function call,
so we have a very basic Shiny
app here for the UI component.
And we're also going to load
the bslib package.
So we can call fluidPage,
although it could really
be any component of Shiny.
And the theme argument will
take bs underscore theme as the argument.
So this will provide
an interface to bslib
and all the different
theming components
you could do, like
background, foreground, fonts,
changing all these different
components in bulk on the page
without having to
write individual css
for each item.
So fluidPage, navbarPage,
bootstrapPage,
all these different
things have the same kind
of theme equals bs_theme argument.
And again, you may have been
using this theme argument,
something like Shiny themes
or writing your own custom
bootstraps css.
Boostrap theme is more
powerful kind of in our minds,
because you are
providing, again,
sass variables and all
the niceties of bootstrap
in there again, to the
power or the ease of use,
kind of both balance together.
Now, something to note here is
that for for bootstrap users,
this is moving
from bootstrap 3, to
bootstrap 4, which is
a more modern, more recent
implementation of bootstrap.
So there is some compatibility
layers here that should help
most Shiny apps just
work out of the box
snd upgrade to bootstrap 4.
However, if you have
some legacy applications,
you could always try
version equals 3 here in the
best argument if it is kind
of messing with your
overall theming.
But for new applications, just
stick to bootstrap 4.
Again, a more recent version
and that'll be the
code recommendation.
You know, in terms of bootstrap 3
versus boostrap 4 for looks,
like really it's hard
to tell the difference,
you might see it here in
terms of like this blue is
a slightly lighter, the fonts
or a little bit different,
maybe not as bold, really
most of the benefits
are behind the scenes,
like just switching
from version 3 to 4
might give you this more
slightly modern looking feel,
but it's not going to change
the core of your application
just with the base theme.
But there are, again, lots of
things built in there that it's
worth upgrading to four.
To preview a theme
and actually get
into some of the bulk of what
these themes can do for you,
you can call this new function
from bslib bs underscore theme
underscore preview.
And this will take bs_theme
as an argument,
and you can provide either
custom themes that you've
built yourself or full
boot swatch themes which
are essentially open
source free themes
that other people have created.
So you can see with
essentially one line of code,
we've taken this basic
Shiney application
in themed every component of it.
So the fonts are different.
This is perpetuated into
all of the dropdown.
So the date, the select inputs,
date ranges, the slider bars,
all of those with respect to the
right colors, the right fonts
and other components
that you're changing,
as well as the kind of
pop-ups or action buttons.
So primary, secondary warnings,
danger buttons, accent colors.
Again, all of this is changing
kind of in bulk and together
in a unified interface.
So if you want to just use
one of these bootswatch
themes out of the box, they're
going to be very powerful
and should be very pretty.
A lot of them have
been kind of used
for front end
development for years.
But you can also
kind of customize
wide portions of your app
with things like sass variables
or other functions
built into bootstrap.
So, again, while I've kind of
hit on this a couple of times,
I really want to
protect people in terms
of don't be scared if
there's things in here
that you haven't seen before,
if you want to learn those,
you'll be even more
powerful, but they're not
necessary to use it.
So if you did want to dive
deeper into sass again,
there's going to be
a presentation right
after this about it.
And there is some documentation
about the sass, R wrapper
for R packages that will let you
kind of learn how to use those.
In short, I'm not going
to read this whole thing,
but sass is really a meta
language on top of css.
So you think of css, it's
changing individual components,
sass would kind of provide a more
elegant or systematic syntax,
letting you change multiple
things at one time.
This usually leads to more
manageable stylesheets
or styling in general.
So I mentioned earlier that
you can create your own theme,
so we showed a pre-built
bootswatch theme.
Now we're using essentially
the same argument, so
bootstrap theme, but
we're kind of mandating
what specific components
we want to change.
So, again, this theme may not
be the most pretty thing to you.
I kind of made it a little
bit garish, just a pop out.
But you can see the
background is grey,
the foreground is black.
So we have a background
of gray and then
the thought will be in black.
The primary color is
this lovely purple, which
goes along with R-Ladies,
and I really do like it, maybe
not with this grey theme.
And then we change the
base font to Francis,
which is kind of, again,
a very different font.
And you can see that the
fonts perpetuated into each
of the different sections.
So, yeah, I don't really
love Frances's as a theme
or as the font, but
you can see that each
of the different parts
are changing, which
is the part to highlight here.
You might also notice that I
didn't have to load externally
a different font, I just said,
pull in this Google font
process, and I could change
it to anything I want.
And it will automatically
pull in the style css
and the Google font,
download it and load it
in your application.
So making it really easy
to import Google Fonts.
And there's hundreds
of different ones.
You could use here, as well
as the most common ones
used in web dev.
If we switch over
to probably a better
pilot in terms of not
one I created randomly,
but one that's based on
something like material dark,
you can again see that we've
changed all the components
at once.
So the backgrounds change.
The foreground is still
this lovely purple.
And then we have a new font.
This time, fira sans,
which is one font.
But I actually really
do like and again, it's
perpetuating this
into the slider's,
into all the different
components all at once.
And with minimal code, I'm able
to create a robustly themed
application.
We'll go over a demo of what
all these different things are,
in short, like this screenshot
shows you the bulk of it,
but you can use Bootstrap
preview with this
to show what plots will look
like, what tables would look
like, notifications,
different fonts,
and you can actually
customize it
live inside the Shiny
application, which
is really cool.
And so I will show
you that right
now in terms of what
the preview looks like,
may pull us over here.
So if I again, I'm
inside RStudio,
I'm just going to pull up this
chunk of here. So bootstrap theme
preview and then providing
it with some arguments
to the bootstrapping component.
So if I run this, it'll
load the Shiny application,
I'll make that full screen
in a second to spin up.
And now here is my
kind of Matrix themed
Shiny application.
So, again, all the
different buttons work.
And I can change
things like the font.
So maybe I don't want fair
armano and I want loto.
I can close that out.
And it will change the fonts.
I can go to accent
colors and say, well, I
don't want the primary
color to be green.
Let's do a f0f0f0
and we'll make it like a white
background or primary color.
And now everything
is here and white.
I can go over to plots and
do let it load for a second.
My CPU is getting some pressure
from me, from the web screen
or webcasting.
So the plots here
are perpetuated
and have those themed as well.
The tables are themed to match
the background notifications,
all these different things.
So, again, as you're
kind of playing around
with different themes,
and want to change them.
You have this
ability to see what
all the different components
of an application look
like without having to write
all this different code just
to test it.
You can obviously, like, run
up your actual production
application locally and see
how it looks with a theming.
But this allows you to
change things really quickly.
All right, so it
closed down that
and go back into the slides.
You can also use bslib
with R Markdown now,
this is somewhat
experimental today
in terms of it is it's
been focused on Shiny
I think that's really what
we want to talk about today is
Shiny but you can imagine
that there are also
R Markdown documents that
have a Shiny runtime or just
R Markdown documents
you're generating
and you want to
theme those as well.
So one of the versions
of R Markdown that
should be merged soon allows
for theme arguments.
So you can change again, the
background, the foreground,
the primary, the base
font, very similar to what
you're doing with your
bstheme theme argument
in Shiny proper.
If you don't want to ride out
the whole theming component
yourself, you can
again get access
to all the boot swatch theme.
So something like solar, you
can pull that in automatically
by name.
And while I'm really excited
about the future of R Markdown,
this is still more
experimental in R Markdown
and you'd have to install this
GitHub version of R Markdown
to test it out.
So maybe wait a little bit
for R Markdown theming,
but Shiny theming
is really going
to be ready in the
next few days, which
is very, very exciting.
Again, for using some of the
bootswatch themes for Shiny
proper in the past, this was
through the shinythemes
package.
So you would load like
solar or darkly or menti,
all these different boot swatch
themes which are listed here
in terms of there's a
full list of, I think, two
or three dozen different
themes you can use.
This is just going to
be loaded with bootswatch,
and then naming it
within whatever fluid component
you have.
There are some newer
themes from bootswatch 4
that weren't
available previously,
and so we are switching
to bootstrap four.
So if you want to
use an older theme,
you could look at older
themes, but there's
some newer ones as well,
that are really, really cool.
Awesome OK, so we've kind of
got over a bunch of things that
are themable, I'm going
to turn over to Shannon
here in a second to walk
through thematic, which
is the complimentary package
to bslib, but things
that are currently themable
And the next CRAN
release, which again,
should be the next few
days, the Shiny package
proper R Markdown HTML document
as long as you have that
specific GitHub version,
DT data tables, which are
perpetuated through Shiny.
And then really any bootstrap
compatible HTML, CSS.
So you can add to this
and add other stylesheets
that are bootstrap compatible.
Some of the other
things that are soon
to be themeable and that the dev
team is working on,
it would love your help in terms
of open source contributions
or asks or different
things that are
working on some of the other
HTML-based R Markdown output
formats.
So beyond just a
document, additionally,
a lot of the HTML widgets have
to be perpetuated through.
So plotly will work
through ggplotly.
But in terms of plotly
proper, reactable,
which is a package similar
to DT for reactive tables.
And in some of the other
extension packages,
like shiny widgets that
provide additional widgets that
are not in Shiny proper.
One of the things that's
fundamentally un-themable
via css and therefore
bootstrap or sass or bslib
is plotOutput or essentially
R based graphics.
So lattice, ggplot,
base R, those are
images, not css in
the classical sense,
where you can change the
components, they're generated
by R. So the way to
get around that is
to use thematic, which
actually translates the CSS
components into these R plots.
So in this case,
we'll use thematic
to further extend the
theme from bslib
into things like
plotting components.
I'm about to be
turning over to Shannon
and she's going to be walking
through the thematic portions.
Yeah, so once you've gotten
your Shiny application
or R Markdown down beautifully
styled with bslib,
one thing that you'll notice
is that the plots are not
automatically styling the
way that Tom just mentioned.
And so that's where you're
going to want to use thematic,
because once you've
gotten that really
nice look to your
Shiny application,
you're going to want to pass
that on to your R plots as well.
So that's where thematic
comes to the rescue.
And what you can
do inside of Shiny
is use this function
thematic underscore shiny,
and you see that we
have that theme set
inside the Shiny application.
And now that setting
is being passed
on to the plots inside
of our Shiny application.
So thematic is giving
those R plots the ability
to translate, as Tom mentions,
the custom styling of the Shiny
application into our styling
and give that plot a very
cohesive look with the rest
of the Shiny application.
So what the thematic
package in general does
is that it changes the
default of the R plots.
And you can use
that thematic underscore shiny
function to turn
the customization
to the plots on inside Shiny.
But you can also use
a function called thematic underscore on
to turn it on globally.
And if you do that, you can
also, within that function,
set the specific background,
foreground, and accent colors
that you want for the plots.
So you can set the
theming of the plot there.
And the other thing
that you can do
is that you can
actually set the font
and we have set the
font here to indie flower
and indie flower is
actually a Google font.
What thematic does
that's really cool
is that it will automatically
download, cache, and register
with R any Google
font that you
want to use inside your R plots.
The other thing that
thematic can do
is in the slide before
this, we customize
the theme of each of the
plots, but we can also, thematic
will also just grab
the auto theming
so it will detect what
the HTML container settings are
of the plot and it'll apply
those to your R plot.
And what that looks like
inside of an RStudio session.
So if you've
turned thematic on,
if you run that function
and you're in RStudio
and you have a
custom appearance,
you're RStudio themes
that is going to auto
detect that RStudio theme.
So you get this actually really
nice look inside your RStudio
session where the plot is
actually looking again,
cohesive with your
RStudio session.
And then similarly,
it'll do that same thing
where it'll automatically
detect your R
Markdown down settings
or your Shiny settings,
and so if you have
used bs underscore theme
and customized your
Shiny application,
the auto detection, the auto
theming inside thematic
is going to be able
to apply the settings,
the aesthetics that you've
set for your Shiny application
to your plots.
So why this matters,
because it's
going to help you to
create really cohesive,
beautiful R Markdown and
Shiny applications after you've
spent all that time customizing
the look of your applications
of your own Markdown report
thematic is going
to let you easily
apply those settings
to your plots
to, again, make everything
look really nice and cohesive.
You can still use
traditional theme settings
inside ggplot
for one-off plots,
but what thematic
will let you do is,
is apply that to
the whole document,
the whole application,
or to all of the plots
that you're making in
RStudio if you want to.
And with that, I'm
going to hand it over
to Tom, who's going to show you
some of thematic in action.
Perfect thanks so much, yeah,
so as Shannon mentioned,
you can use it
with R Markdown,
you can use inside Shiny
and then it will
also work directly
within kind of just an
interactive session.
So here
I'm going to load the thematic
and ggplot plot libraries.
I will turn thematic on just
as Shannon showed in the slide
deck, like we're setting
basically a theme
for everything in the session.
And then I can just
create a ggplot.
So this is a very simple mtcars
ggplot that
everyone is looking for.
And it will perpetuate
what I asked it
to here into the
plotting panel in terms,
we have that red theme, we have
the white and black background.
For me specifically, I'm using
the dracula RStudio theme,
so if I didn't want to
perpetuate something forward,
I could actually
just tell it to use
whatever is in my environment.
So in this case, what's
going on in RStudio.
So I can create the
plot, call the plot,
and again, it will kind of use
the pink and the dark purple
and the black and the gray that
is made up of the RStudio
theme I'm using.
For bslib and Shiny,
the bootstrapping preview,
we did, we'll also show you a
plot that automatically themes
the plotting portion because
it's calling thematic
as well. For R Markdown
we showed that you could
do thematic and bslib
for those items proper.
So here I have a theme component
inside in R Markdown doc.
So it's an HTML document.
And then I'm calling
audio for thematic here
because it's going
to reflect whatever
the bslib components are.
So if I missed this, it
will actually go through.
This is again,
just the basic RMD.
It's got a base R plot, a summary plot,
and then a summary function.
We'll let that build
in the background.
And I'll show you
real quick what
that goes to wrap things up.
All right, over here.
So, again, this is
perpetuating all the components
into R Markdown, so the font
is obviously vastly different.
It's using this nice purple
as the primary color.
The base R plot has
been reflected to also
be cohesive with the overall
theme and ggplot as well.
So, again, this idea of you can
theme Shiny, you can theme plots,
you can theme R Markdown
all by using similar syntax.
Let me pull up the
slides on this rebuild.
The beauty of R Markdown slide
is I think I closed it down,
so I'll just rebuild it real
quick, and we'll close it all.
Let's get all
the way to the end here.
All right, so, yeah,
Thank you for hanging out
with us for the past
about 25, 30 minutes.
In summary, you can
use bslib
to theme Shiny and R Markdown.
This will upgrade to
bootstrap 4 by default.
If you're having apps breaking,
you can always downgrade
to version equals 3.
You can use bootswatch
or custom design
for your own custom themes.
You can use bootstrap
underscore theme preview
or bootstrap
underscore themer to
quickly preview and update
themes interactively.
There's a full blown article
about theming with bslib
here that we'll
share in a second.
And you can use thematic for
easier theming of R plots
in conjunction
with bootstrap lib.
So R Markdown, base R,
ggplot, lattice,
all these different
components can be perpetuated
with the theming through.
I'd like to thank Carson
Sievert for letting
us adapt part of his slides,
and thank you to Appsilon
for bringing us in today.
They're going to have a lot
of wonderful presentations
about sass and more theming
and their semantic package,
which is a way of getting
further away from what
traditional Shiny apps look like
into really, really custom
really, really
cool applications.
And I will stop talking.
And thanks for your time.